the kansas city chiefs are already very
well positioned for the postseason with
patrick mahomes and i think we've seen
time and again
in patrick mahomes 20 nfl starts that he
truly is a special talent maybe the best
quarterback we've ever seen now that
doesn't mean he's going to continue to
play that way but he kind of is who he
is he moves the way he does he throws
the way he does barring injury this guy
is going to continue to be
special in a way that we've never
witnessed so
i saw some talk renewed yesterday about
what his contract will be worth the next
time he signs a deal with the chiefs
he's still operating under the terms of
the contract that he signed as the 10th
overall pick back in 2017. and adam
schefter of espn has mentioned a couple
times now back in january the first time
and yesterday the most recent that
mahomes will sign a deal worth 200
million or more and that really isn't a
shock because it'll be a five-year
extension worth 40 million a year you do
the math that's 200 million dollars the
question is how much will be gained
guaranteed what will the full structure
be and more importantly
when will they do this deal because
people think that a player isn't
eligible for a contract until his third
season ends and they're right but the
key word is third regular season and
there are people in the league who don't
know this because i've had the
conversation i said look here's the page
of the cba where it says completion of
the third regular season the day after
week 17 the chiefs and patrick mahomes
could sign a long-term contract and if
i'm mahomes if i'm his agents i'm laying
the foundation now to tell the team i
want that contract the day after the end
of the regular season the money you get
playing those postseason games is
peanuts in comparison to what you make
in your game checks and it's definitely
peanuts in comparison to what he would
make on a new contract why put your
future payday at risk through extra
postseason games when the window is
already open on a long-term deal that's
what he needs to be pushing for now will
the chiefs comply when we interviewed
clark hunt the owner of the chiefs back
in march he said we've got some
opportunities and we're keenly aware of
the fact that when you have a young
quarterback the cap burden allows you to
build the team around him
so they may not be budgeting
a big contract for patrick mahomes until
we get into 2020 until after march but
if they're wise they will clear out cap
space now they will have enough left
over that they can sign patrick mahomes
to his new deal during the 2019 league
year and as soon as the 2019 regular
season ends because mahomes deserves it
and he should be clamoring for it and
look there's no real leverage here
because it's not like he's going to walk
out but at the same time the right thing
to do given the special talent that the
chiefs now have and that they hope to
have for the next 10 15 20 years get him
taken care of financially as soon as
possible and the first possible day is
the day after the 2019 regular season
ends actually it's after the game ends
do it that night have it ready to go
that's what the chiefs should do because
when you have a great player you need to
recognize it and you need to act
accordingly and mahomes great guy hasn't
changed incredible quarterback it would
be very wise of the chiefs to pay him
what he's worth the moment that they're
able to do so that's it for today's pft
ot check us out all weekend long at
profootballtalk.com we'll be back on
monday with another edition of pft live
more pft pms coming throughout the week
but for now the focus is on week four
and we will do everything we can to get
you ready to go for all the action that
is to come have a great weekend and
we'll talk monday
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports